and shy if you want to
share your slides sure yes
um okay
can you see it yes yeah perfect
okay so next we have a shy moran from
the technion who is going to tell us
about the equivalence between private
prediction and online classification
okay yes so thank you for the
for the invitation so i guess i have 45
minutes which means
okay good so just take the time okay so
yeah so hello to everyone and um
i'll talk today about a few papers
actually
and this is joint work with um maliante
maliades
noga alone roy livni and mark ban
whose pictures you can see and maybe
before we start just an
uh a comment is that the way this
uh this idea of that to this work was uh
was conceived was via results in model
theory
actually that mariante introduced
[Music]
to us so this is just a kind of uh
i don't know non-standard way of
getting results in computer science
okay so yeah so
so this talk is about differentially
private learning so
so private machine learning what is it
when is it relevant
so um so one example which we'll use
throughout this talk is that imagine
that you have a
deep neural doctor okay and then uh
so your family doctor comes to you one
day and asks you to share your medical
record to train
a deep neural doctor and
of course most people may want to help
but also some of them may be afraid that
this can cause a terrible event because
it is personal and sometimes sensitive
data
whose exposure may may cause some bad
events
um and this is indeed like uh not only a
third example but it is a real
world issue of more learning algorithms
using
personal and sensitive data
and therefore it is a relevant problem
to study
so the tldr version of our main result
is that
so the question we ask is which tasks
can be learned
while protecting private data and the
answer is that any task which is online
learnable
and i'll soon give all the necessary
definitions but let me just mention that
online learning is
kind of a mature area which has been
studied for for several decades
while private machine learning is is a
young area
so the definition of differential
privacy is just
maybe 15 years old
and the first paper in in private
machine learning was probably 2010 or
something like that
so 10 years ago um
okay and then let me know that while
this gives like a kind of a general
abstract result it manifests connections
that were
previously noticed and
and exploited and yeah so there are some
results that
you know notice that whenever you have
an online learning algorithm
in many cases it is automatically
differentially private
and also there are some works in the
opposite direction where
where they use differential privacy to
to design online
algorithms with with excellent
guarantees
so yeah so
we just give kind of a formal and
abstract
manifestation of these connections okay
so let's say
let's start to discuss some formal
definitions so formally what you prove
is that private pack learning
is equivalent to online learning and let
me quickly define these
these models so
uh yeah so the pack learn setting as i
suppose most of you will know so we
assume there is a class of
boolean functions from a domain x
there is some unknown distribution over
examples that we wish to learn
and we assume that this the target
function the labeling function is a
concept from the class it's a function
from this
from this class and we get a training
sample
from this distribution and the goal is
to output a function f
which is close to the to the target
concept
with respect to the metric induced by
the distribution
okay so this is just the standard
definition of back learning
and we say that the class h is black
learnable
if there exists an algorithm whose
population loss vanished
with the number of examples as the
number of examples goes to infinity
the the population loss of the algorithm
goes to zero
and this should happen in a uniform rate
over all possible distributions d
uh yeah okay so that was the pac
learning part what is the private part
how we do how do we define
mathematically
private uh
privacy so um
so again let's go back to to our
definition to our
example so we have this this um
doctor who wants to use our data to to
train
a neural doctor and then and
the patient wants to contribute but
afraid that this will cause
a terrible event e so what differential
privacy
allows the doctor to say allows the
scientists to to say to the patient is
that
whatever event e that you're afraid of
the likelihood of this event
will not be affected by the decision by
your decision to participate or not
more formally the likelihood of all
events
remain almost the same when adding
removing a single data point
okay so so so that's the definition of
privacy and we'll give the the the
quantified version but
but but this is the the the essence of
it so
any particular person whether they
contribute their data or not
will not affect the likelihood of any
future event
um which is resulting by this experiment
by this
by the training so this is a strong form
of stability as you can see
okay so now let's define it formally so
um
so we will need the following notation
so for two numbers uh so so
fixed epsilon and delta in zero one
these are the privacy parameters
so let us denote that x
and y are equal up to epsilon delta if
x is at most it will be epsilon times y
plus delta and vice versa and y is at
most e to the epsilon times x plus delta
so if we remember that e to the epsilon
is roughly one plus epsilon
then we see that up to an alpha in
transformation which is almost identity
x and y are the same number
and now we say the two distributions p
and q
are epsilon delta in distinguishable if
for every event e
the probabilities the measures p of e
and q of e
are epsilon delta equal to each other
okay so with this notation we can define
what what is an algorithm differentially
private
um so
um
so assume a is a randomized algorithm i
want to define when is
a differentially private so um so in our
case
the algorithm gets an input sample so
it's a sequence of examples and it
outputs
a hypothesis but it's really a
randomized hypothesis because we assume
the algorithm is randomized
so we can think of a of s as a
distribution over hypothesis
where the distribution depends on the
random bits of the algorithm a
okay so we say that a is epsilon delta
differentially private
if for every pair of neighboring samples
s and s prime
so for every pair of input samples they
disagree on a
single example so they're all the same
except for a single example
we have the distributions of the output
a of s and a of s prime are
indistinguishable or epsilon delta
indistinguishable
this is exactly what we what we said
informally before
so every the likelihood of every event
will not change by much if we just
change a single example
and let me just know that epsilon is a
is usually taken to be a constant so
let's say 0.1
while delta should be negligible
with m comparing to one over m
okay so these are the the standard
setting of parameters
okay um and now
when do we say that a class is learnable
in a differentially private way
so first of all it has to be plaque
learnable but then we also require that
the learning algorithm
that learns it is differentially private
okay so this is a differentially private
background ability
by the way if there are any questions
please please interrupt me
and i feel like i'm talking to myself
um you're not alone it's okay okay good
we're listening
it's okay a quick question um
so afs is a multi-output function right
no a of s is a so a is a random and
whenever you have a randomized algorithm
once you give it an input
you get a distribution over outputs and
each output is
a vector or is it a single
in our context each output is just a is
an hypothesis right it's a function
okay but we have learned algorithms so
they get input samples as
inputs and they produce boolean
functions as outputs
okay so we have such a randomized
algorithm the input is
is the sample the output is a hypothesis
but since the
algorithm is randomized we we view the
output as a distribution of hypothesis
right okay okay and then the
differential privacy means that whenever
you change the input in one point
these output distributions remain
roughly the same
in this in this precise sense
okay great thank you
okay so again differential practice
learnability
is just sparkling ability by a dp
algorithm
okay so we defined the left-hand side of
the equivalence
now let's let's view the the model for
the right-hand side
so this is online learning in the binary
label case
so again as before we have a class of
binary functions
and now we look at this online learning
model
which proceeds in t capital t iterations
in each iteration
our algorithm receives a question which
is just an
instance in in the domain then it
predicts
an answer label in plus -1
then it receives the true answer which
is also in plus minus one
and it suffers a loss if the predicted
label
is is different from the from the true
label
so if it made made a mistake
and the goal is to minimize the
the regret what we call the regret so
the regret is the
total number of mistakes made by the
algorithm
comparing to the total number of
mistakes made by the best function in
the class
capital h in particular one interesting
uh
setting is when there exists a function
in the class that makes no mistakes
i.e when this infimum is zero
and then we just want to minimize the
number of mistakes
okay so um so there is no distribution
now over examples we
there is an adversary if you will that
asks us these questions and reveals us
these labels
and our goal is to make as few mistakes
as possible
where the comparator class is again this
class h
of boolean functions
okay so um
so what when when do we say that a class
of h
the class h is on a learnable so the
definition here if there exists an
algorithm
that can learn it so against any
adversarially produced sequence
it can learn it with a
subliminal regret so the total number of
mistakes
will only exceed the best functioning
class
by some sub linear function
okay and let me
let me stress that the input sequence
here is adversarial
so it's not stochastic like in the pac
setting it it can be arbitrary
and let me also notice um just so i can
ask you some open questions that it is
captured by
a combinatorial parameter called the
little dimension
which we will define later but for now
just know that there is this
combinatorial parameter that is assigned
to the class h
it is similar to the vc dimension for
those of you who know
and this the finiteness of this
parameter determines the only
reliability
and furthermore the this function the
optimal regret bound
is also determined by this um by this
combinatorial parameter
okay so that's it we defined what when
is the class
privately packed learnable and we
defined one is a class online
learner bell and now we're going to say
that that every class
satisfies is privately packed vulnerable
if and only if it is only learnable
so this is the main result so the
following
are equivalent for any class h of wooden
functions
so h can be learned in a differentially
private
manner in the pack setting edge can be
online land
and the third item is the h has this
finitely some dimension which i still
haven't defined but for now we remember
it's just a
combinatorial parameter assigned to the
class
um yes and as as we will
discuss soon the proof is really based
on a combinatorial perspective
of learning and also we introduce a new
notion of algorithmic stability which
may be of independent interest
we will discuss all of these soon
for now let me just tell you quickly
about about
an immediate application that we have
that we have that we can
so you know every class that we know is
only learnable
is also differentially private back
learnable
so of course this includes all finite
classes
but this was already known that these
the final classes are differentially
private
bachelor but there are also some
interesting examples of infinite classes
that are on the learner ballot and the
henceforth are also
a private pac learnable so you can take
hamming balls over an infinite domain
take alpha and subspaces of any of any
vector
space uh more general solutions to
to systems of polynomial equalities not
inequalities but equalities so
like the varieties
daniel mentioned before half physicists
with margin
and there are many many many more
examples from model theory so it turns
out and this is the connection to model
theory that
this nielsen dimension is um
[Music]
it's like uh it's a very important
parameter there and it defines
what they call stable theories and there
are many many examples for stable
theories and
any class which is the final but in
stable theory
has finitely some dimension so this
gives you
many examples which maybe are esoteric
in machine learning but mathematically
very rich
okay and uh before we go into the
technical uh
so for sure technical overview let me
just mention one open question
so although we proved this equivalence
the the equivalence is really only
qualitative
at least what we proved in particular
the lower bound on the sample complexity
of private pack learning
scales with log style of the leads and
dimension
okay so it is very very small
and the upper bound that we proved is
exponential in the least dimension
and this was just improved i think a
week ago
by ghazi golovich kumar and vanuanzi
to d to the sixth or something like this
so it's probably not the right answer
but it's a
very significant improvement over our
exponential
upper bound and
but in any case even polynomial in d is
still
very very very far away from log star d
um and and
we know that log star d is sometimes
almost tight so there are examples of
classes with little student dimension d
that can be learned in poly log study
number of examples but this can
potentially be completely avoided
and and i guess one conjecture that
that i can state is that the sample
complexity is really polynomial in the
vc dimension so this dimension is
back learning without any restrictions
and in the log star of the leads on
dimension if this conjunction is true it
means that
the dilution dimension only has a very
very negligible
effect on the sample complexity
and this conjecture is supported by a
line of work
for a forks for dp learning half spaces
okay so there are some reasons to
believe this conjecture but
yeah it is it is wide open
um is it known because without the log
star dependence on the or some
dependence on the little stone dimension
again again is it known that uh is it
some dependence on the little stone
dimension necessary
yeah so this is this is our result right
so the sample complexity is always at
least
log star of the decimal dimension okay
and it's a differentially private
background
yeah this is the for differentially
private back learning okay so
so we know that the sample complexity is
finite if and only if the limits on
dimension is finite
right this is what this this
inequalities tell you
but how finite we have no idea and it
could be
as far as we know that it's really the
the
you know it's very very mild dependence
of log style
okay
okay any other questions
okay so
let's say let's do a quick technical
overview
and then i'll ask some open questions in
the end if i have time
okay so um as i said the equivalence is
qualitative
it's based on a combinatorial
perspective and a new notion of
algorithmic stability um
so really so let's talk a little bit
about the combinatorics
in the proof so first of all
for the context that we just mentioned
that you know there is a
combinatorial parameters really are
often
often arising in machine learning in
learning complexities
so probably the most famous one is back
learning versus the bc dimension and
then there is what we mentioned the
online learning and lesson dimension
but there are many other examples
and essentially whenever you have a min
max
statistical problem my experience is
that there is a combinatorial parameter
behind it that
that captures the learnable objects
um okay so let's discuss these two
uh important examples of vc dimension
and releasing dimension and now i will
also define
what this lesson dimension is
so first let's recall the definition of
the vc dimension
so the base dimension of of a class h is
the maximum size of a set which is
shattered by age right so
we want when is a set when is a subset
of the domain charted by
h it is shattered by h when you have
when you restrict
h to this x one up to x d to these
points
then you see all possible two to the d
binary patterns
another way to think about it is is um
and this way is useful for defining
listen dimension
is that you have a binary tree at the
root you have x1
the second level is labeled by x2
the third level by x3 and so on
and and if we think of it as a decision
tree
so this dimension so this set is
shuttered if and only if
every path in this decision tree
is realized by some function in h
okay throughout this three x one labels
the root x to the second level x to the
third level and so on
if every path is realized by some
function in h
then this amounts to this set being
shattered
and really the vc dimension is the
deepest such
it's the depth of the deepest such tree
which is shattered by
h okay
and i hope this is clear so what is the
wilson dimension
this one dimension is the same thing
only that we don't require
the tree to have the same label
over the over each level right so now we
allow that
at the same level you'll have different
labels so for instance here
the root is labeled x1 and the second
level is labeled x2 and x3
so it's not the same variable and so on
and so forth
so the least dimension of h is the
maximum size of
a complete binary tree which is
shattered
by the class h
okay so in particular it can be much
deeper than the vc dimension because we
don't require the labels to be the same
does it make sense definition so here
you mean
size and not depth of the tree depth
depth
okay okay yeah okay yeah this is uh
this is um uh yeah it's a depth it's the
depth of the tree
okay and let's see an example where the
two
well the dimension is much much deeper
than the vc dimension
uh so consider uh
thresholds okay so one dimensional
threshold function right so all
indicators of thresholds in rp
all half lines in in r1 in the on the
real line
okay so the vc dimension is only one
here because um
we never we never we can never shutter a
set of two points because we can never
see
in this example uh
i guess zero and then one
but if you look at this binary
search tree which we can continue
indefinitely
it is shattered by this class right it's
a
[Music]
right it just tells us in this binary
search essentially looks for the
threshold
um okay
so this is for yeah so so this is an
example where the two
where the where you know when the vc
dimension is one but the listening
dimension is really
infinity uh okay
so now for so the vc dimension as i
i suppose most of you know characterizes
sparkling ability
so a class h is learnable without any
privacy restrictions
just in the classical sense if and only
if it has a finite vc dimension
d and moreover this dimension captures
the
sample complexity of fact learning up to
log factors
um okay
and for leads and dimension we have the
same result
only when we replace spock learning by
online learning
so class h is only limitable if and only
if it has a finite different dimension
and furthermore we have the same kind of
characterization of the
regret bounds
um okay
so with this result it suffices to show
that
differentially private learning is
possible
if and only if the leaves and dimension
is finite
right we don't have to think about
really about on and learn algorithms
we can just walk with this combinatorial
parameter
although one direction in the proof will
use online learning
okay so yeah so
we proved these two directions in two
different papers
so the first direction that if the
differential
if the pack is differentially private
learnable then there is no machines
finite within the first paypal
and then this year we prove the converse
and let's begin with the first direction
that any class that is private pak
turnable
must have at least finitely some
dimension
so really what we will prove will be the
converse so we will show that if the
dimension is unbounded then
the class cannot be differentially
private pacliana bill
and i want to just quickly discuss in a
non-technical fashion two central ideas
in the proof
so the first one is that it suffices to
focus on
one dimensional thresholds and the
second one
is uh is that
one has to detect hard distributions
here in a non-standard
way and the way we do it is via ramsay
theory
so let's discuss these two points now
so for the first point actually there is
also a nice open question related to it
but first i want to define to give a
definition
so what is the threshold dimension of a
class of functions
so the threshold dimension of a class of
function h we denote it but
by t d of h is the maximal integer k
such that we can find x 1 up to x k
and h 1 up to h k so we can find k
points in k
functions such that h i of
x j is one if and only if i is greater
equal than j
okay so really if you look at the
metrics at the bottom matrix
the incidence matrix of these points and
functions you really get this
triangular matrix
okay so the threshold dimension is the
maximum k
such that we can find the triangular
metrics in the incidence matrix of the
class
um yeah so really what it means is that
the class
contains a subclass of k thresholds
right and this is the maximal subclass
of threshold you can find in there
and just a comment is that this can be
thought of as a combinatorial
generalization of the of margin margin
is a geometric concept in the context of
half spaces
um
okay so here is a theorem that uh
that we did not know about and this is
something that mariana told us uh it was
known for
model theorists since uh since the
seventies
and but here is but but it's a very
interesting uh
interesting result so it turns out that
for every class h
the leafs and dimension and the
threshold dimension they have this
exponential
um at most can exponential dependence
between them so the ellipse dimension is
bounded
it's upper bounded by two to the
threshold dimension
and is lower bounded by the log of the
threshold dimension
okay so um and and by the way uh
this is the open question i wanted to
note so this is tight so we know of
examples
actually the examples of one-dimensional
thresholds
they they uh satisfy this inequality
with an equality if you just have
thresholds over 1 to n
but here we don't know whether it's tied
so we know that
there's always an inequality but maybe
it can be improved
um
okay and again if we think about the
margin
comment from before then this really
kind of so if
since dilution dimension captures online
learning they mistake bound
so we see that this connection between
the threshold dimension and
mistake bound can be seen as a again an
abstract extension of the mistake bound
margin connection for half spaces
so with enough imagination you can you
can
make this analogy
but really the takeaway message in the
context of our of our paper
is that if the releasing dimension is
large then h
contains a loud subclass of thresholds
right so whenever the relational
dimension is very big
then we can find the witness for it in
the form of
of many thresholds of of
in this class
any questions about this this is
okay
okay so it's sufficient to show that the
class of thresholds
over some large domain is not privately
learnable
right this is the takeaway we we as we
said we wanted to prove the converse
that if the leads and dimension is large
and the class is not privately learnable
but we know by this result that if the
limits on dimension is large
then there are also many many thresholds
in the class i actually there is a
question by ashwin let me just allow him
to talk
okay when you can ask your question
um yeah just a quick question about the
upper bound so you said it's not tight
and something is open so what is known
in terms of
a tight upper bound like something we
know is achievable
not much we thought about it for for
some time and uh
i think we have some
um yeah anyways
not my like very very weak bounds we
have it's not exactly stated in this
form
um but uh but really nothing is known
uh essentially nothing is known so if
you if you consider like
actual threshold functions up to a
certain
you know level of granularity then it's
a case where the little stone dimension
is equal to the special dimension
okay so if you take thresholds up to
from one to n
okay then you can have a binary then
you're gonna have a binary
then you can have a binary search tree
of depth log n
so the leads and dimension is um
is going to be log n and the threshold
dimension is going to be n
okay so it's tight for the lower bound
yes exactly
but for the upper bound we don't know
okay so
yeah so again so we want to show that
class with unboundedly some dimension is
underneath is not perfectly learnable
so in this class we identify many
thresholds and we just focus on
thresholds
okay so previous results for this
context in this context show
that proper private learning is
impossible for thresholds
and also that it's impossible to earn
thresholds if we insist on
pure differential privacy which just
means that the delta parameter if you
remember in the epson delta privacy
is set to zero but it remained open
since
15 so first almost five years it was
open whether you can
[Music]
you can do anything better
and okay so so how to prove the lower
bound for threshold so
again the goal is to show that every
differentially private algorithm a
cannot learn thresholds
so we need to find a high distribution d
for a
right we have a an algorithm a that is
differentially private we need to find a
distribution which witnesses this a does
not learn threshold
typically in in in machine learning and
more generally in computer science we do
it by a minimax approach
okay so we find a single hard
distribution which is hard
for all algorithms
yeah construct a single d which is hard
for all algorithms
so for example in in the pac setting if
you take a distribution over a shuttered
set
and this is how you prove that the lower
bound of this dimension for pac learning
so it's a single hard distribution over
a shuttle set
the interesting and challenging fact
here
is that this cannot work if the marginal
distribution is known
then the threshold and in fact every vc
class
is pac learnable okay if the marginal
distribution not the target function
only the marginal distribution is known
then every vc class
can be pack learnable and the idea is
very simple you just
pick a finite cover for the class so uh
you can cover the class with respect to
the metric induced by the distribution
the disagreement
is the measure of disagreement between
functions
and and then you can learn a finite
class using the exponential mechanism in
a differentially private way
so so really we cannot
use this we cannot we we cannot hope to
construct a single marginal distribution
which witnesses
that thresholds are not privately
learnable
so we must tailor d in a way that
depends on the algorithm a
and the challenge is that a is really an
arbitrary learning algorithm it may be
improper
we really there is not much we can use
about a except the fact that it is a
mapping from samples
to hypotheses
what can we possibly use to construct
this distribution d
so the the idea is to use ramsey theory
so i will soon state what ramses theorem
says but let me just
know that ramses theory will allow us to
detect in an algorithm-dependent way so
given an algorithm a
i will be able to detect a large subset
x prime of the domain
such that if we only give a inputs from
x prime
then the behavior of the algorithm on
this set is very very predictable it's
highly regular we can control it and
then we can exploit it
to prove a lower bound
so this is the high level idea so again
like the usual
mini max kind of approach that we
usually see is replaced by a ramsey
theory
by ramsey theorem which which gives you
uh which tailors actually have
distribution
in an algorithm-dependent way
um yeah and yeah so d is going to be
uniform on x prime
on this large set on which a is highly
regular
will you say what you mean by highly
regular and i mean will you explain this
a bit more
um i didn't plan to
i plan to just stay trump's ethereum but
but i can say a few words on this
[Music]
so yeah so highly regular means that
so if you remember um we talk about like
the classes three episodes right so x
x the domain x is linearly ordered
every pair of elements in x these are
just real numbers you can compare them
yes the behavior of a highly regular
means that
a is
comparison based it can only use use
comparisons
to in when it access that accesses the
input
okay so this is what highly regular
means and it's not exactly accurate but
it's
but let's say it's a but this is the
idea yeah so
so essentially what ramsay theory tells
you is that you can only restrict
yourself to comparison based learning
algorithms and comparison based learning
algorithms are
much easier to handle
okay so right so comparison based means
that if you get
two samples um
then the output of the algorithm really
only depends
on the kind of the other type of defense
of the sample
and not um but yeah i'm not going to say
more so so
regular means that the algorithm is
comparison based
this is a this is precise enough
okay i don't know if it helps but uh
but but at least maybe you can believe
that comparison based algorithm are uh
are are very are much easier to
understand than alberta algorithms that
may use the
you know the whether the number is
rational or not for instance
sure okay
okay so ramsey theorem um
um yeah so it's you know ramsey theory
is a
philosophy by now but uh but the
original theorem um
so yeah so that maybe the the the
version that everyone learns
is that whenever you have a group of six
people then you can either find in it
three mutual friends or three mutual
strangers
so if you have a graph on six points and
and every edge in this graph you color
in one of two colors red or green then
you can either find a
a green rectangular a green triangle or
a red triangle
here you can find both here is a red
triangle
more generally whenever you have a
ground set
t and you color all
n tuples of t using the k colors
right so here for instance n is a three
so this
triplet is red this triplet is purple
distributivity is green and so on
then ramsey's theorem tells you that you
can there is
a finite uh
lower bound r which depends only on n m
and k
such that whenever the domain is larger
than
r then you can always find the
monochromatic set
of size m and the monochromatic set is
just a set
where all where all tuples of
of s have the same color
um and what we do is we
we take the algorithm and if the
algorithm uses
m examples to learn then we we color all
m tuples of the domain
in in a very particular way
and then from the homogenic set from the
monochromatic set
which is given to us by ramsey theorem
this is the the the set x prime on which
the algorithm is regular
so yeah so again this is really just a
rough overview i hope it gives you
something
and let me just comment that the most
technical part
which is also quite short is after the
application of from z
so it's to derive the lower bound with
respect to the
comparison based algorithm if you will
to do the regular algorithm okay so any
any questions about this
um about this part
okay so let's see how much actually how
much time do i have seb
if any sorry 10 like 15 minutes 10 15
minutes
ah i still have 15 good okay i wasn't
sure yeah
great great awesome okay so we're done
with the
with the first direction let me now uh
say a few words about the second
direction that whenever deletion
dimension is bounded
then there actually is a private back
learner right so
that online learning implies private
path learning
okay
so the proof has two steps the first
step
we will show that if the dilution
dimension is finite
or more precisely if the class is only
learnable here we really going to use
online learning
then there is something we called we
call a globally stable learner
and then from this globally stable
learner it will be quite uh
straightforward or at least stand out to
derive a
differentially private learner
um so what is this so so as you can see
i
central notion here is global stability
globally stable learner let me define
what what this
is so a learning algorithm
a is globally stable
if for every distribution d the
existing hypothesis h which depends only
on the distribution d
such that whenever you apply a
on random samples from d on random
inputs from d
then you will see h the output will be
this
will be this opposite of this h we've
bounded away from zero probability the
probability at least a constant which is
bounded away from zero
okay so it means there exists a frequent
hypothesis
so for every distribution d there will
be a frequent hypothesis
that the algorithm will output and if
you think about it
it's it's it's similarity it resembles
the variant of
pseudo-deterministic algorithms
which was defined by gotten gold vessel
right so absolute deterministic
algorithms are randomized algorithm
such whose the mapping they they compute
is
almost deterministic right so for every
input there is a particular output
that is outputted with high probability
so
it's kind of a randomized algorithm that
computes a deterministic map
and here it's it's the same idea but
only in the
learning setting so for every
distribution
there will be a particular hypothesis
which is assigned to this distribution
okay and the reason we call it global
global stability okay let's
this maybe i'll do in the next slide i i
i messed up in terms of the time i'm
sorry
and that's what i thought yeah yeah so
maybe
maybe it would be good to wrap up
actually because uh
yeah we're already over time i'm really
sorry about that
okay so
[Music]
um okay so let's uh
yeah so so let's just uh wrap up
let's see if there's anything short i
can say
yeah so as we said like the main result
was that uh differentially private path
learnability and only vulnerability are
equivalent
um yeah and that the proof was
based on a commentary perspective and
this global stability which we didn't
define unfortunately
uh yeah and i guess that's it yeah the
open questions will take a while so
let's uh
yeah okay
yes so thank you thanks shy sorry about
that
maybe we can have the slides online if
people want to look at the open
questions
of course no problem perfect okay so
let's take a
quick five minutes uh break and then we
will be back
at 10 30 for the talk by lee yang 10
so let's take a five minute break thanks
again shai
thank you